oh hello
guys I in New York City right now wow
there is not that bright thing that you
can't see trust me I'm not in heaven I'm
in New York I'm here because I'm
attending the Webby Awards tonight and I
haven't posted a video yet today because
it's been a whirlwind couple days
getting here so I thought I would shoot
a get ready with me for the Webby Awards
video killing all the birds with
one Stu
that I keep having to go pick up and
rethrow because I'm not a good shot
let's see um how how do the beauty girls
do this okay
D oh no that's going to be this is a
terrible angle okay hold on everything's
terrible let's see what is are you
looking at the ceiling okay let me check
this I didn't bring my camera and I
didn't bring a tripod I didn't think
this through so I'm just going to we're
going to hope for the best I don't know
if you're going to stop filming at some
point okay first step in getting ready
for the wees let's take a
shot it's so
big I know that's what she said I did a
very terrible time packing for this trip
because I it was all very last minute so
um I went and bought all sorts of drster
makeup yay mini haul can see it can you
see it can you see it can you see it and
I bought a new curling iron look a new
hair dild should I do my makeup or my
hair first
first I'll do my makeup I'm sorry if you
chose hair but you chose wrong just
double check that you're still filming
you make me very nervous are you smudged
oh how rude throwback Thursday Stephanie
Tanner I mean
Michelle huh joke first I Ed this you
see it Maybelline Dream matte mousse
this is my go-to Foundation all the time
and I paint it on forgot first thing I
do is I use this K's facial fuel eye
depuffer because my eyes have been puffy
I don't know if you put it on your
eyelids but I
do
look now they look like two deflated
balloons then we just my hands are clean
I just got a shower we go like this
[Music]
W that looks like a thing great then I
wash my hands then I use my Bobby Brown
shout out throw back Thursday Grace's
faces it's not Thursday tinted eye
brightener Mark gave me this
specifically because he knows that I
didn't need it whereas
I didn't know am I doing it Mark don't
answer cuz I'm probably doing it wrong
now um what do I then no I make a
sentence I'm using this Rimmel natural
bronzer and this thing you see it and I
put it on this area cuz I've seen Tanya
bur do this every girl once they want
their face to look like there's two
bowls on the side the lighting in this
back bathroom is really terrible for um
applying makeup because I don't think
these colors are accurate so it's always
a fun time when I go out in public and I
see myself and I realize oh that's
what you look like so my bless is
Maybelline new master
glaze and I'm using it because it's the
only one that I found in my bag no I'm
not embarrassed I'm just and blushed now
on the eye shadow I bought cir this what
it has the word fard Accent on the back
I don't know what that means fard f a r
d I sincerely hope that that's the color
name fart
accent I knew I liked
you oh gosh now you just blew it I going
use my fingers because we all came from
caveman there's no shame in that game
first I'm going to put this white color
white under my eyebrow
bone because that makes you look
like
Illuminati I mean
illuminated Frei and slip then I'm also
going to take it and put it in my inner
tear duct because that makes you look
like you actually slept last night when
you know you didn't you took a red eye
to New York okay then I'm going to take
this middle color the middle child in
this Trio just like me and just put it
all over the lids then I'm going to take
the last color the dark one and put it
in the crease to create a shadow because
we got all these bones on our face that
we have to make look like different
bones okay yeah now I'm going to do
eyeliner you guys know I love liquid
liner so I'm just going to make to the
best of my ability some winged eyeliner
and what really happens when I do winged
eyeliner is that they don't match so I
end up just building building building
until my entire eyelid is covered in
black eyeliner and then I call it
purposeful BRB guys you guys I did the
thing where they didn't match and so now
I am wearing a ton of black
eyeliner but it's okay purposeful right
now on do my mascara I use Maybelline
the falsies because Miss glamorazzi
loves it this is a really
flattering angle I hope you guys are
appreciating this I'm going to use this
curling iron
and see what happens watch this I do
this and then I take the one of
these a little one and then I
do with this and then I go like
this oh
Magic
oh so
subtle hey look see subtle little things
I just keep doing that the whole
time I won't bore you guys with this go
get a snack oh oh hello welcome back
okay I'm going to hold this up here now
because I can this so this is basically
what the hair is looking like tonight
like
um like a floppy
7s male Rockstar also I need to decide
what I'm wearing I packed so poorly I I
might just wear wearing yellow shorts
can you see that there you go I might
just wear this outfit with
heels I'm from the internet I don't have
to be fancy right I don't
know